Bitcoin is a fully digital currency.
You can exchange bitcoins between computers in a worldwide peer-to-peer network.
The whole point of most peer-to-peer networks is sharing stuff,...
...like letting people make copies of super legal music or movies to download.
If bitcoin is a digital currency,...
...what's stopping you from making a bunch of counterfeit copies and becoming fabulously wealthy?
Well, unlike an MP3 or a video file,...
...a bitcoin isn't a string of data that can be duplicated.
A bitcoin is actually an entry on a huge, global ledger called the blockchain,..
...for reasons we'll get to in a minute.
The blockchain records every bitcoin transaction that has ever happened.
And, as of late 2016, the complete ledger is about 107 gigabytes of data.
So, when you send someone bitcoins, it's not like you're sending them a bunch of files.
Instead, you're basically writing the exchange down on that big ledger,...
...something like, "Michael sends Hank five bitcoins."
Now, maybe you're thinking, "But, wait."
"You said that bitcoin doesn't have a central authority to keep track of everything!"
Even though the blockchain is a central record, there's no official group of people...
...who update the ledger and keep track of everybody's money like a bank does.
It's decentralized.
In fact, anybody can volunteer to keep the blockchain up to date with all the new transactions...
...and a ton of people do.
It all works because there are lots of people keeping track of the same thing...
...to make sure all transactions are accurate.